what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
who's got a question a problem something
i can help with who wants to go first
what do you got for me today so i got to
a really big aha moment and my question
is
understanding someone else's who
um and especially parents
kind of on the on the same stream of
thought from last week when we were
talking about obstacles and how um
becoming the teacher or becoming the
parent with your own parents and setting
business hours
um
thinking about their who and uh
how to talk to their who versus mine and
i'm still learning mine
my who i have five different hashtags
and i'm still trying to figure out my
who and i'm sleeping on it and weaken up
and i think um
my who is changing
and uh i'm gonna just start off with
this i have uh
adventure as my who okay
and
because i have a lot of energy and every
time i think of happiness it's more of
adventurous it's more of a more
adventurous with everything
and then
my credo which i'm finishing up
i have
discipline
i have
compassion
and i have
energy
and it changes every every combination
okay wait so
what's changing is the adventure at the
top changing of the three underneath
that are changing it feels like the
three underneath are changing okay i i
invested in
a years ago um a trademarked my name
laura explora
and because i'm an explorer and i'm an
adventure and everything i do it really
comes down to that when i wake up every
morning that's what it is and so
that for me is a no-brainer it's more of
it's more of adventure than explore i'm
more like
i'm more optimistic and adventurous
versus just explore
but the three
pieces of my credo keep changing
and i have words all over the place and
um
i think ubuntu
was a word because connection is very
big for me and i kept saying
connection is so as you can see
connection is so important to me that
it's if i don't have that
nothing is right in my life
so i have to kick one of the three out
and put connection or ubuntu because i
believe everything we're all connected
ubuntu is that what you're saying yeah
okay and if i understand it correctly
that that word means we're all
we're all connected everything is uh
everything is uh
together everything is connected that
word it's
together connectedness is everything to
me okay but it's but it does that go
with the top is it actually everything
or is adventure everything
there you go that's evan i
i don't know
i think it's everything i think ubuntu
is everything more than adventure i
think adventurous piece of the puzzle
okay
how do i know
this is a hard question this is not a
head question you don't know you feel
yeah
what feels the best
well nothing seems right unless
i'm connected
not in a codependent way
not and i can't be alone way but a
connection i thrive on that and i know
when i'm
feeling starved or
something's missing it's because i'm
missing that big piece of the puzzle and
once i get it
i'm much better everything's much better
the example is last week
for me connecting
was
a rocket ship for me with everything so
therefore
adventure
went down and ubuntu connection
connection how do you spell ubuntu
i believe it's you ub
u n
t o
t u
o t u okay i looked it up and it's like
it's a software company so then so i
gotta find it yeah then it'll come up
it's it's an
african word an african phrase i believe
and and someone should work with me one
time
and it resonated with me and it came up
out of nowhere
last night and i went oh that that's the
one well so here's something interesting
so i looked it up it says a quality that
includes the essential human virtues
compassion and humanity
so we already have compassion showing up
as part of the definition passion is
already there
so we may not need that in our credo if
it already means compassion and
connection
so how do we get how do we get ubuntu
for you
or ubuntu am i saying that right ubuntu
i think so okay so how do we get that
for you what is that what does that mean
to you if you had to think about what
what is underneath or how do you get the
connection
it has to be a good connection it has to
be a positive connection it has to be
uh how do you get there how do you get
to a good connection what do you what do
you need to do like what think about the
children of
connection
so like adventure or exploring is
somewhere in there you get connected to
adventure yes okay
reaching out and serving people
connection
okay
it's an interesting
i feel like my i'm on a quest
i'm always on an adventure to find
connection
and so therefore that's where i
that's good well like adventure and
quest are
are sisters right like they're pretty
close you can pick which one but it's
it's different than if you're if you're
going like adventure i get i get
connection or get ubuntu through
adventure i get ubuntu through serving
or service
yes and then you get it through
what's another way that you can get
connection or ubuntu for you
well i think an important part is also
self um
uh self connection always
for sure yeah i mean i don't i don't
know that i did a good enough job
honestly in the book explaining that
part but whatever you come up with as
your who you need it for yourself
as well as what you give to the world so
i need more belief for myself yes always
it's a never-ending mountain that you're
climbing yes and you're trying to give
that to the world as well yes
so 100 so self is already built in so
ubuntu for yourself and ubuntu for the
world right but how do we and so how
about this this discipline fit in there
or is it
i i feel like
there's a discipline rituals um learning
focus um
i don't know i'm in the woods
but it's actually pretty close the grass
actually i think yeah yeah i like it
but look if i put it into i'm going to
put this into the chat here yeah for you
to read it but here's what i wrote down
so you got ubuntu at the top and then
you have adventure requests and you have
service and you have discipline rituals
focused like those are all
uh
you could pick like take your choice
between adventure and quest they're
close it's basically the same thing like
one might mean something slightly
different cool like whatever you
resonate the most you said you like
adventure more than explorer right
it's still like the same thing it's the
same family it's close enough so go with
adventure cool i love it yes yes service
is number two cool and then between
discipline ritual focus they're all in
the same category
so you pick which one feels the most
right to you like i can't tell you which
one this is a heart thing it's a laura
heart thing between the three of those
and you don't have to have the answer
right now but you know that whenever
you're you're lacking
happiness it's because you don't have
connection
that's the number one to self yeah you
know connection and like but it also
means compassion right to self and then
or you feel like the work you're doing
is not connecting to other people and
there's no compassion for others right
but then how do you get it well we have
to go on an adventure or we have to go
on a quest yes it has to be something
that fun and new and exciting not just
the same usual boring stuff especially
for you
like nobody likes photocopying their
same day over and over but especially
for you that's going to be if it's the
lara is going to the same thing every
day you're going to hate your life but i
find adventure in that like i see i seem
to find adventure in the mundane i can
make it fun this came from what do you
love best about your parents that they
taught you i had to think hard and it
was oh my god i can do anything and i
can make it fun
adventure yeah well but now instead of
only having it be like a coping
mechanism to help you get through the
boring we can seek out more adventure
so you have to be doing more bold more
fun more big more new
if laura's the same person in a year
she's not going to be happy she has to
be doing something
and it's fine it's like part of your
thing is adventure request yes but then
that's not it it has to be service you
have to tie it to helping people there
has to be some kind of mission it's not
just a selfish thing for you
to go bungee jumping yeah adventure like
it's got to be tied into helping
somebody else somehow yeah
and then and then discipline ritual
focus somewhere and there that this is
this is planned out it's not just you
hope inspiration hits you
it's just like all over the place
creative artists it's like it's got to
have it's got to be factored in you need
your schedule it has to be focused yeah
so
that that all works and so whenever
you're not happy it's like it's one of
these three things that are leading all
of those things lead to ubuntu for you
and something in there is missing either
you don't have enough adventure you
don't feel like you're serving people or
or it's not focused or disciplined
enough
that it's consistently happening
so you've got it i think you just need
to get a little more you're not in the
grass anymore i mean visually you are
might be but uh it's really just down to
between those words what do you like
what feels better adventure request
or discipline rituals focus because
they're all like we're hitting the right
buckets just what do you want to name
the bucket so that it becomes more clear
but
that's amazing you've got it oh my
goodness evan that was this morning
because i i actually thank you and i but
i was actually finding um
i was looking up hawaiian uh
words there are some hawaiian words that
actually mean
so much more than just the word
where
it was it was hitting um ubuntu is like
there's uh
there's um oahu which is family
um connection
outside of like family of origin but
we're all family you know words like
that um but even picking ubuntu as a
word shows the adventure quest side of
you like no i'm not picking a normal
english word
well yeah i thought i was almost close
to drawing a symbol because i i couldn't
put my finger in the language
i'm seeing the experience but i can't
put my finger on what to call it but now
i'm getting closer yeah um okay wow this
is big for me it's
it was a solid week of
every challenge i think yay i think it's
i really uh
i went through a very big challenge over
the past week
an adventure actually i really looked at
it as a very intense adventure i'm like
oh
what do i like about this and how am i
approaching this and i believe it's
because i'm looking at it like an
adventure but i am having connection and
it's about connection and i'm gonna find
okay yeah and then like if we peel back
so one i mean amazing we've got it great
you still have to narrow down like you
said adventure is so much more than
quest it feels like adventure is more
the thing than quest but
you know between adventure and then
discipline rituals focus which of the
three just
names the bucket better
with all of these things
it's it's both kind of
attached to what we're currently doing
as well as new things we're seeking out
so
in the couple examples you've already
shared there's the coping mechanism of i
can turn
something that is mundane into an
adventure that's what i love about my
parents right cool there's also the oh
this is challenge in front of me but i'm
going to reframe it as an adventure
instead of a challenge right so like
whatever we're already doing we can
reframe it to feel
more connected to so this is actually an
adventure as opposed to something
challenging but it can also lead to new
so like how do we analyze our current
life but then also going forward if you
now have to plan out or think about
where you want to be doing for the next
12 months how can we
with discipline
put some adventure into our calendar as
opposed just to reacting to what we're
currently experiencing
yes yes exactly
being responsible with the discipline
right so you're right
his focus okay you're just reframing
what you've currently got which is great
which will make you happier like same
thing if you took service your second
part of your credo yes you could take
the mundane
and if you can flip at the service
you'll show up differently
yes you'll
service as in uh share or teach or
sure yeah whatever it means to you but
like if you could take the thing if you
take something boring right now and you
found a way to be able to help somebody
else out through that thing you'll start
to feel more connected immediately to
the work that you're doing yes
that's that's so that's more of like a
coping mechanism reframing as opposed to
seeking out new things that if you said
i want to bring more service to the
world in the next year what new things
can i go off and
and create and put it into my schedule
so it becomes a focus or becomes a
discipline do you get the difference you
can see in a different way
so
go back to adventure for example right
so you're talking about the two coping
mechanisms you've been using are one
if it's born or mundane i can say it's
an adventure and then i'm i'm now i'm
good right
okay or this is so that's what you learn
from your parents there's this big
challenge in front of me it's an
obstacle i'm going to turn into an
adventure and so now i'm going to be
more inspired and motivated to go work
on it so you're flipping the current
situations yes into adventure so now
you're going to show up differently yes
right
so that but that's taking our current
life and just reframing it
yes towards adventure which is fine it's
a coping mechanism it's awesome
now instead of just taking our current
life and making it more adventure
what does building an adventure life
look like
um
going after this with discipline and
focus yes something that you're not
doing that you've never done before but
would be fun to go on this new adventure
a new quest or new exploration
so it's injecting new into our
discipline and routine and focus as
opposed to just reacting to what we
currently have got it this is this is
adding
this formula
am i getting
okay so it's adding this formula to
the going forward not just the actual
present challenge yeah
right so what are we going to add what's
what's new that we're going to create
that's going to lead to even more
adventure so with with intent we're
going to create a new adventure for
ourselves going forward
as opposed to just reacting to what we
currently have as opposed to reaction
so you're asking me that question you're
asking well you don't have to have an
answer right away but it's like it's
just the
thought process yeah that if you had to
with intention now to say okay
i'm going to
over the next year i want to bring in
more adventure bring in more service
bringing more discipline and focus into
my life what does that life now look
like
that i'm creating for myself the people
i'm around the new things i'm signing up
and doing the the products i'm launching
the book i'm gonna write the speaking
gig that i'm gonna like whatever that
new adventure is that you want to go on
but it's something new that you're
creating as opposed to just reframing
what currently is
got it yes so that's the movement the
action for the movement yes um i'm
working on that right now i um
i i finally felt free enough to get to
that part
after i figured this out
because you because i was spending
89 percent of my time focused on the
challenge instead of
the challenge and then focus
90 of my time on what new can i create
um that's that was a real big shift for
me um
which is which is by reading
um
i've gotten to that point which i feel
is huge
it is i mean this is great i'll put it
again in the chat so you can see it and
everybody else can too but
like that is huge because if you're not
happy it's because you're not you're not
feeling in connection to ubuntu which
breaks down to adventure service
discipline
one of those areas have to be
hit stronger for you to feel more
connection right
and going forward
what can i do to create that
being more intentionable now designing a
life what is an intentional life around
ubuntu look like for you versus reaction
to this yes i get it i'm there i'm right
there all right we got it
not leaving you laura
but what a creation i got it yeah and
it's always both it's like reacting to
current life and creating new it's we
need
ubuntu our belief for ourselves and what
we want to share with the world it's
always inwards and outwards yes and both
oh i love
evan thank you cool well thanks for uh
volunteering and allowing us to deep
dive and
you know again it's one of the things
like after you write the book you
realize oh i wish i talked about that a
little bit more so it's great that we
got a chance to go deeper here on this
call
oh maria's got her hand up what do we
got maria
hey evan good to see you
so i'm i'm wondering um i've been
learning a lot about facebook reels and
somebody i i
respect said that it's like really
gaining momentum now
so what are your thoughts on facebook
reels
and and and can you i don't know if you
if you know can you do like a facebook
reel and then just upload it to
instagram
or
i would go the other way around
instagram first and then to real so when
you're sharing a real you have the
option to post to facebook like most of
the instagram stuff you have an option
to post to facebook as well
so
i i love the idea of repurposing content
if you're making content anyway just
put it everywhere
um
if you care about twitter then the
easiest thing to do is do she's like i
don't know like 45 seconds
twitter the max is 45 seconds so if you
watch me in the morning i'll be walking
i walk outside every morning and i'm on
my believe walk and i'll make a quick
video about what today is going to be
all about and i keep it the 45 seconds
because of twitter
the other ones are all a minute as your
max
vertical video but i'll do 45 seconds on
twitter share my thoughts of the day and
then
i'll post to every platform
so um we'll actually keep it as a as a
story for instagram and facebook but it
could be a real that you use instead i'm
reals are
super popular i'm i'm i'm in but i would
just take the real design for instagram
first
um or tiktok first either one and then
take it to the other platforms so your
reel goes to facebook it goes instagram
it goes to tic toc goes to youtube
shorts
so you can do that right after you make
the reel like
in your in your or do you have to
download and upload it yeah i'll usually
record it as a as a like a video on my
phone like an actual video video okay um
if you want to use any of the editing
features
inside any of the tools then
then you can upload it like you can
record it natively in those tools and
then download it and and put it to the
platforms but if you're going to make be
making content anyway you might as well
post it to
all the platforms if you don't care
about twitter then you have up to a
minute and you can put i don't know
about twitter yet i'm like on the verge
of like overwhelmed with like then
that's fine then don't worry about it
you know but instagram and and facebook
are so connected
that it makes sense to do that and then
um
yeah if you're i would i would put it on
tick tock and youtube as well but if
it's too overwhelming at the beginning
then don't stress about it like a lot of
these things is just building momentum
to the to the you know the new book you
just build momentum because at the
beginning it takes a while to get used
to the thing that you're doing but once
you're doing it it goes a lot faster you
know like if you're helping
if you're helping um
you know women deal with some of their
emotional baggage and issues like some
of the exercises that you give people
is overwhelming at the beginning and and
when you say you're going to make this a
new habit that that's
that's really hard at the beginning to
build that habit but once they get used
to it you know whatever you're asking
them to do on a daily basis once they
get used to it's like oh this actually
i'm getting used to it's not that hard
my first video took me two days to make
one video right
like
sitting down memorizing lines and now we
can like i bust out i recorded 20 videos
yesterday right it's just a lot easier
zayn saw like what zayn we recorded 10
videos in like an hour or something
they're an hour and a half in vegas
right i mean i was in vegas with zan a
couple of weeks ago or something and we
had a little bit of time so hey you want
to come to my hotel room and let's film
some videos and me drew and zan
sat down and we just filmed some content
but that would have taken me so long to
do at the start of my career
and now it's just so much easier because
we've done it so
if you feel overwhelmed by everything
cool go go smaller just do
just do instagram facebook awesome
so you so you record it to your phone
and then when you do the really there's
a place to just put the reel up there
yeah you can do that or if you if you
like using some of the editing tools
inside instagram then you can use those
editing tools and then post
but again it's like not being so
overwhelmed by all the options and all
the tools and like
they give you a lot of options and they
can be really cool but it can also be
overwhelming and then you don't post
anything
right um
uh yesterday on my instagram live we did
one with orlando who's been in movie
makers for over a year and uh
he hasn't posted content a long time
because it just said it was overthinking
so many like what do i call it and just
so many options that then nothing
happens
so
uh does it make sense strategically to
put it on every platform yes
but
not at the expense of not doing anything
yes so
if you if you find the tools too
overwhelming to even just post to
instagram reels cool don't don't worry
about the tools yet you'll get there
okay just focus on the message and then
once the message becomes easy and that's
routine then we can add another level
another level another level
great thanks so much evan yeah all right
cool
izumi's got our hand up what do we got
is umi
hi evan and hi everyone i finally made
it i usually have class on thursday
afternoon so i can
it's hard for me to join but today it's
open so i have a question i love it and
yeah or anyone can contribute or
give me ideas so
now that everyone's coming out we're
mixed you know talking and i share with
my story but i do
and then i was like oh that's
interesting
and then
one mom said like i'd like to know
what's going to happen what you're going
to do
so we exchanged
or i gave her my numbers and said oh
yeah we can connect on linkedin but
nothing happens and that's kind of has
been happening like some people are
interested in my story
when we meet in person
but i i have a hard time keep that
connection
through social media or whatever it is
um
from your experience or anyone's
experience what's the best way to kind
of connect in
long term in social media emails or
so what i do i i usually suck at staying
in touch with people i'm really bad at
it i don't remember i'm introverted i
don't have friends so it's like i don't
need the connection a lot like i get i
have mover makers i've you guys this is
amazing right i have i have this group
like that's where i get most of my as
long as i have nina
then i'm good for for like in person
stuff but
but i realize how important it is for
business so what i do is every
uh i have a list of the top 100 people
that i want to stay in touch with
and i schedule in every friday
i'm looking at that list to see the last
time that i checked in with them
and uh if it's been over three months i
find a way to reach back out and stay in
touch
um and some of them are some of the
outreach is very basic
um
you know yesterday for example um i
don't if you guys know alex from mosey
or not but he's another creator um
and
we took a picture together at grow with
video live in vegas and i posted it to
my pinterest and when you post a
pinterest underneath it it says
other pictures that you might like that
are similar and underneath our picture
with all of these chris evans is his
name chris evans the captain america guy
with the beard uh when he had the beard
um he doesn't have a beard in captain
america but he has he like had a bunch
of pictures with a beard so i take a
video of it and send it to alex hey alex
i posted a picture to pinterest and
underneath is all of these captain
america pictures like i think uh i think
the world's telling us that you should
be a superhero right send it to him and
he sends it back like lol thank you for
this um so sometimes i do something fun
like that right and then i can i can
check on my list okay i messaged it alex
on you know june 29th
and so if i haven't connected with alex
in the past three months since then then
i'll find someone something else to
reach out to alex about so sometimes
it's something fun like that sometimes
it's
what are they working on in their
business uh the easiest way to do is
look at what they're posting on
instagram what are they posting on on
instagram or twitter or tic toc wherever
they're most active what are they
posting and how can you react to it how
can you
i'll send a message hey congratulations
on
x right or i love that post you did like
more than just a comment on their on
their post but i'll send them a message
and often a video message you know like
i probably sent you a video message
um
walking outside in the park like hey
zoom me happy thursday you know just
something quick as a way just to stay in
touch with people
um
and i find that
super helpful so you make your list of
the 100 people who you've met who you
want to stay in touch with and then at
least every quarter if you want to make
it every month that's fine too
you find a way i hopefully they're
posting something like the more they're
actually posting content the the easier
it is but if they haven't posted
anything you can just say hey
julie i was thinking about you today
hope you're doing well
and just sending you lots of love give
me give me an update on where you're at
like it doesn't have to be a follow-up
yet to the thing that you talked about
but just as a way to stay in touch
my messages usually aren't the most
inspiring you know like when i'm walking
on the in the park
zooming how you doing happy thursday
sunny here in toronto sending you some
love thinking about you have a great
week believe send right next but it's
like it's on my heart i'm thinking about
you but i i don't have anything
necessarily super inspiring to say but
it it just keeps you
top of mind so
um if you if you struggle
like nina's great at that stuff just
naturally
my wife nina she'll just remember things
and she's like i wonder how you know
zan's doing we should we should send
zayn like oh yeah yeah it's a great idea
but i don't default to thinking that way
so i have to schedule it in and that
might seem more like cold and calculated
but it's love
i just don't remember
uh so back to like lore and discipline
like i need more i need discipline to do
it or i won't do it
um so that's what i would do like when
you meet people at an event or somebody
wants to hear more about your story
find a way to if you just get their
phone number cool that's great there's
nothing wrong with sending a text
message and saying hey i was thinking
about you
um send it as an audio so they can hear
they can hear your voice they send it as
a video so you can see your face
and if they're on social then
instagram dms are usually the the best
um
that you can send videos or audios as
well as an easy way to stay in touch
okay
yeah i think that's the problem that
happened this past weekend was that i
only gave my number and i didn't get
hers
ah so
yeah it's like there you go i can i
can't even message her so what i love
doing there is i will if and i'm i i
suck at texting too and i forget to stay
in touch with people but when when
there's somebody who i'm messaging on
text and we exchange the phone numbers
i'll i'll i'll send them a message but
in that message like okay what's your
number i'll send you a message right now
and then i'll i'll take a picture of us
like okay here hey send
so that
they know who it's from
and so that i remember who they are and
like what we just did because i don't
remember names as well easily too so
like you see at the top like oh yeah
yeah yeah that's jason okay cool cool
cool that's how we met and so it's a fun
thing as well so i'll send i'll send you
a text right now so i'll send them the
text and i'll take a picture with us and
they're smiling in it as that reminder
for both of us because then they get
some random number text them like oh oh
that's evan um
so that's a little hack that that i use
as well so yes get their number
ask if they're on instagram or ask where
they post if they post content they may
not
you know like in this group everybody
should be posting content but um
if you're meeting people out in the wild
then they may not be posting um but yeah
that's an easy hack to get going
that's smart
thank you so much good luck kazumi
thanks for joining in
just a generic q a session now to help
you whatever you're struggling with and
uh let's open it up so zoom user in the
house welcome aboard zoom user what do
we got
everyone my name is lily bettinato
lilly
yeah so i'm actually coming from a
caregiver
line of work and
i'm now uh going to start uh coaching
whereas
how uh caregivers can reunite families
especially coming here to canada
and how they're gonna start canada in
the house i love it okay great
i'm from toronto we're just neighbors oh
wow we're not we're neighbors
so
that's what my idea but uh you're spoken
about the va
so i'm thinking uh where to get the help
for a va so to set up my back office
and so to to make this like you know
like already set up
before i start my webinar
so
two options one
would be any personal connections
that you have a lot of the home care
uh people at least here in canada are
from the philippines yep that's and
so if you already have connections in
there there's a lot of people in the
philippines also who are doing va work
as well
um so it could be personal
connections and saying let everybody
know
in in the in your caregiver community
that you're looking to hire somebody in
the philippines to help
with your va work
and
you might you know land on somebody
great um the good thing about that is
they're connected to the to the
caregiver community already because
they're
they're a friend or a family of somebody
who is a caregiver here in toronto right
or canada yeah yeah um so
those are some recommendations um and
that's just letting your friends know
and letting the people letting your
customers know hey i'm looking to hire
somebody who can do this for me
the second is we use upwork so up like
up and then work is where you can hire
people
around the world for different projects
if anybody's hiring like you can just go
a lot faster
when you have people helping you and it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money like
when i was given the advice to maria
i could have said hey maria you go out
and make this list and you go out and
she's already rolling her eyes she could
do it but
for the amount that it's going to cost
her it's it's just not worth it right
it's just not worth it for her to put
the list together and email people but
for her to be on the first call
absolutely like we don't want dylan on
is anybody here named dylan i don't
think so we're using dylan as an example
okay um we don't want dylan to be
making the first call because he
probably won't know what to say we need
that to go to maria so like where is the
highest leverage for her part-time
worker overseas um
just makes a lot of sense and for a lot
of people like that's a great job you
know a lot of people who work for me
um
did not did not like their job prior
might have been traveling two or three
hours out of town like each way to get
to their job and come back to do some
call service you know call call center
service work um
you're gonna treat them like a human
being like they their boss i mean most
bosses suck so here you are like
actually caring about them
um
so it's a great it's a great life for
them as well not just you know you get
work off your off your plate
um so yeah upwork is great what i'd
recommend for anybody who's looking to
hire an upwork is
even for even just hiring period work on
something small together first
work on something small together first
make sure you like them make sure
there's a good vibe there make sure
they're um they're skilled they're doing
the work well
um they're not you know taking longer
than they should
um they're not
asking dumb questions or asking no
questions right like it's a good vibe
uh and so when we hire
we might we might end up hiring 10 or 20
people for a position where we have one
opening
and
we it's paid so like it's not just
volunteer for us but we'll pay them to
do a trial job
and whoever really needs the nina's the
asset test now you know like if you're
going to work at our company you have to
get along with nina
or there's problems so
so hey if you if you like work nina
likes working with you
boom you're hired let's go and you have
the skill set obviously but it's in that
you know we'll give we'll hire people
for
up to five hours on a job we think
should take two hours
wow amazing
and then if the person who we like
working with the most who also brings
you know does the job obviously but it
was a pleasure working with then um then
we'll go
deeper with them
um and that's what i love doing like
it's for me it's still
vibe first
and then this is like for submit here
and we're still around but um
when you're hiring it's it's vibe first
too like heart first he's there he's on
his phone
like heart first on the hiring and then
still head you're not just hiring
somebody because you love them when you
think it's everything's going to work
out and be amazing they still have to be
able to do the job but but heart first
like if you went to work and you love
the people you're working with
then um
a lot more great things can happen you
know i mean like i see zane here
when zayn dan and i were talking about
him in movie makers and being involved
helping in the early you know the intros
for it and being the built to serve
coach
i wasn't looking for a build to serve
coach
you know like i didn't i didn't i didn't
i didn't want one it wasn't was not on
my road map or idea list but zen was
one just so amazing as a human
pouring so much love into other people
and how much love he had for built to
serve
was amazing like he knows the book
better than i do
uh he's like page
85 here's what it says he's got copies
that are falling apart because he's read
it so much like the pages are falling
out and all over the place
uh it's just like i love this human
we should i need to do something with
him
like i want i need to find a way to do
something more with him and so that it
led to this right so i think you should
vibe first
and so you won't know that just by um
by a cover letter
it's also like the recommendation of
chris to actually fly out or drive out
eight hours to go see the guy because he
can feel like the heart
you'll get a you'll get a better
structure and a better deal likely than
even definitely over an email but then
doing it over a zoom
yeah
thank you so much
i have a technical question though if i
if i want to search for people on
instagram in my niche because i also
work with women that are needing wanting
to release weight and more emotional
eating and it's a sensitive issue
um do i just in the search put hashtag
what i'm looking for and then what
happens or tell me what to do like the
technical piece yeah yeah so in the
search bar at the top it depends if
you're using desktop or mobile but still
this you can search you put in
emotional eating
but then it brings it'll often bring me
to like somebody
who's well like i just put in
women weight loss and then it comes to
some like a coach that's like that's her
page
so at the it'll give you options you can
do people and also say hashtags you can
click on the hashtags and then see
another way around it is you when you're
searching like woman weight loss don't
put a space in there
because hashtags can't have spaces right
i mean sometimes underscores or whatever
but but
you will get a mix of people who are
also doing what you're doing those are
the people that we want to skip
okay right more than one comes up
like you go to different hashtags or
when you go to that hashtag does it open
up oh
i'm sorry i'm like really learning how
to do instagram yeah yeah yeah yeah no
it's good when you click on the hashtag
it'll show you what
the top posts are for that thing and
then the most recent posts as well oh
it'll show me the posts okay and then
and then you can click on them and see
so you're you're going after the people
who are not like you unless you have a
model right like
maybe part of chris's new business could
also be
also helping other people who are
trainers train better
you know like if he's searching up dad
bod he'll get some people who are also
trying to promote their
personal training business
yeah and he could reach out to them and
say hey
i've been doing this for x number of
years if you need help growing your
business
i i'm happy to hop on a call and help
you
right that's a different mod i don't
know if chris wants to go after that
audience or not other other trainers
he's like maybe like cool you know like
ditch it i don't care
options right so if they're your
competition and you don't you don't have
anything to help them with then you skip
them and move to the people same thing
for you like you have you have emotional
eating
as a hashtag and you get some people who
are deeply in it and are frustrated with
it and are just seeking some kind of
validation or emotional support by
posting on instagram
and that's a very empathetic
outreach you'll have other people though
who are making fun of it who are posting
like a cartoon or a funny meme or
and so then you lean in on the humor and
you can say hey but if you're actually
sung with us like i could help you
and your and the goal is to flip them
and so just play with both and then see
which one
one feels more natural and heartfelt for
you and two where you're getting results
from people
yeah yeah i have one more question if
that's okay
yeah
so my work really lends itself to
working in collaboration with
nutritionists with um you know i'm a
food psychology coach but i i work
really with addictive you know the
addictive piece so doctors people that
have clients that are struggling and
they know what to do but they just can't
do it
so is that something on instagram that i
would do like maybe reach out to to the
people with those niches also and and
see about some form of collaboration
yeah instagram
and maybe linkedin
this is where i would see like the
challenges that the people who are at
the top
probably aren't making a lot of content
like the top professionals in almost any
field are not making a ton of content
most of them
so are the top
doctors making a ton of instagram
content probably not maybe but in
professional fields doctors lawyers
accountants generally really suck at
making content
they're just all referral-based business
and they're not enough some are but for
the most part they're not um but you
could like if you put
nutrition tips
or nutritionist you know as as a search
in instagram you'll see who's posting
all of those people are they're giving
their nutrition tips or their
nutritionist
uh
you have to do a little bit of work to
see how
you know is this person
of a certain level i don't know how you
know they're just getting started maybe
it's not worth the time
um
but it's a great way to find partners
for your business especially if it's
anywhere in the us like if you can
partner with somebody in la or in
balmy cleveland
[Laughter]
you know
yeah it's a great way to be able to find
people and set up some partnership
arrangements you'll just get a bunch of
people who also are at the early stage
of their company and may not be able to
give you a lot of referrals so it might
be there might be some tire kicking
there
um until you find the ones you can you
can gain a sense like do they have
their own location you know do they have
a retail center do they have a place you
can actually go visit them or is it just
a home office or
all online
you know just to have some criteria for
who you work with but um i love
partnerships because
they can instead of going one to one to
one to one now you're targeting one
person they can introduce you to 10 100
000 people yeah yeah well my had my
brick and mortar business my best
referral was through a naturopath clinic
because they had me go there regularly
meet the clients and
and they you know they weren't able to
do what the national path was asking
them to do and i was helpful in helping
them do that could you do that anywhere
in north america
yeah if i mean virtually yeah i mean
honestly might even better since you've
already done that with naturopath
clinics
um i would look at hiring a va
to make a list of every naturopath
clinic in north
america
and then give them a give them a maria
lipuma email address
you know
dylan at maria lipuma
and now dylan is emailing everybody to
say
hey would you like to talk to maria
about this
right that's great and you create a
little script for them to send off
like dylan is not a full-time person at
your company dylan's just researching
and and sending out emails
from your company and then
when they say yes most people will
ignore it
or goes to spam or whatever great
and then some people will say okay yeah
let's hop on a call
and then dylan gives it to you and maria
takes over honestly like that's if you
have that model already worked out
that's already happened for you
that'll be faster for you to grow your
business and i can use testimonials and
all that in the yeah well all you need
to do is get somebody on a call
because you've already done it before
that'll be much faster than doing it
through
social media
okay so so hiring a va to get me a list
of the naturopaths in north america and
sort of create an email that they can
just send out inviting them to have a
chat with me
okay great great idea thank you evan oh
thank you so much for what you
bring i'm just
amazed by you you're
amazing powerful power of example i know
i'm embarrassing you but
really
i'm gonna turn i'm gonna turn this red
now i'm gonna turn that color on my face
now because of you maria um but listen
as much as i love content and youtube
it's not always the best next step
right like honestly for you
you just need to have enough of a
profile that if they look you up on
instagram there's something there
or youtube like there's something there
if i put in your name like who is this
maria person is she legit there's
something there that shows enough of
what you do
um
yeah and then the va is making the email
list
you have to make the email don't expect
them to like write the email right you
make the email and then the va sending
out the email
and they're going to how many how many
natural path clinics are there in north
america
i mean
crazy a lot yeah i mean in my 10 in the
next two towns around here there's a lot
yeah
so if you have like if you get one
percent of one percent of one percent
you already have more business than you
know what to do with
that's great
yeah
this week was about youtube so maria i
was asking about youtube tips uh since
it's a nice intimate group maria do you
wanna do you wanna unmike and tell us
about
what you're working on and how i can
help with youtube thank you evan i know
that you have a lot of um information on
youtube and i'm pretty new to movement
makers so i've been going through the
training materials and and this year my
focus is to is to clean up my youtube
channel to optimize it to make better
videos i'm really motivated and focused
to
to
grow my audience in that way but i just
thought that i know that you have a lot
of information out there but any
thing off the top of your head or tips
about um
like i'm going through with some of the
things i've learned from your trainings
about changing some of my thumbnails and
my titles
and then also i have to you know i'm
really learning how to make better
videos like engaging at the very
beginning and and so the more i do that
so right now i'm committed to making a
new video once a week
um i'm thinking even more than that once
i get really back on track with feeling
better yeah um
but um yeah this is my goal this year
that's really how i i found you and
decided to jump into movement makers is
i was looking for some guidance in in
that area
cool well welcome to movement maker it's
good to have you there too let me just
load up your youtube and for anybody
who's thinking youtube
are you nervous maria are you nervous
well i feel a little embarrassed look at
all these people who are all going to
look at your stuff together isn't that
amazing let's give her some claps
there you go maria
it's messy
this is all it's all it's all fun so
this is you right this is me yes this is
the channel body confidence solutions
with maria correct all right cool so
this is a channel so
uh
it's great that you have you know a
banner and you've got your thumbnail
here it's great that it matches it could
be obviously wider so that it
it fills up more of the space but that's
it's a good start you're linking off to
a
lead magnet yeah
a book three essential steps to stop
emotional eating
got it so i would probably do a picture
of the book because when i land on this
page this is great it says ebook stop
emotional eating and then i land here
and i see health conscious women
okay like show me the book
okay it'll be great to see the book it's
great that you're doing this that you
have a
a a landing page you can start to get
business from it but a little more
obvious so i don't know i guess it says
it here
yeah but but you're forcing the women to
come and
do more work as opposed to
but yeah like where's the cover show me
the cover of
the ebook so i know i'm getting
an ebook
great but but this is great um
content looks like you've been making
two days ago five days ago two days ago
three weeks ago so we're getting there
we're making our content i like it is it
is it through tapping or are you doing
coaching too or what are you doing so i
do all of that i'm i'm a i do tapping
i'm a master practitioner but i also am
a food psychology coach and so i
specialize in helping women that are
struggling with usually the deeper
drivers that are having difficulty
aligning their lifestyle with you know
weight loss body confidence
food addictions emotional eating and so
i do a combination of my youtubes are
some coaching some tapping um a lot i
have a lot of tapping in and actually um
oh you know i'm definitely have to go
through these and actually weed out ones
that are more broad or maybe not
specific to my niche
but um and some of them are
not really good at all but i just wanna
i wouldn't worry about what you've done
in the past just move forward yes going
forward
uh you could have more playlists here so
uploads is a great one i'd have popular
uploads as a second one and then have
more playlists
underneath so when people come to your
channel they can see more content so if
you go to mine you'll see uploads
popular uploads right so that's great
that that's your certain uploads have
popular uploads next and then have
different
um
playlists so this is interviews that
i've done okay and then shorts and then
my gaming channel and then so you can
have different playlists with different
content that you're putting up so you're
giving people an option to go and click
through and see
so if you're doing like you can have a
playlist for tapping you can have a
playlist for coaching like whatever you
want to make money doing i'd love to see
that as an example here too
and then super quick um
let's let's just load up your recent
video and see what's going on here oh
gosh do you find yourself in a pattern
of releasing excess weight feeling slim
and healthy and then bam before you know
it the weight comes back on again and
there we go how does it feel watching
yourself back maria well i didn't have
my voice there but yeah it feels a
little weird but yeah i'm i just putting
them up i love it i love it listen it
took me
350 videos until i wasn't completely
embarrassed for my own stuff
um and 700 until i inspired myself so
you're already way ahead of me okay so
what i love this is actually much better
than i expected uh
just in time when most youtubers are
getting started they
the intro is really poor so the only
thing missing from here is just energy
level okay yeah so i actually want to
say that i based on what i learned in in
the in your book and in your frame i've
changed my intro the last few videos to
do more like this and definitely i
realize that's the thing i have to bring
more of my energy to it yeah so for
anybody who's this it's a youtube
strategy but it's also for all social
content if you if you picked up built to
serve and you've read it it shows the
template for a perfect thought
leadership video and so you're doing
great here that right away you find
yourself in a pattern of releasing
excess weight so you're already the only
thing i would change instead of asking a
question i would make a statement okay
what do you believe about
releasing excess weight
that other people don't believe and we
can role play this and hopefully
everybody benefits from it what do you
actually believe about losing excess
weight that most people don't believe
okay so the thing that gets me crazy and
it's coming to me right lately is and
this is definitely
it's like if i hear one more person
going on keto or this other crazy diet
it's like we don't need another diet we
what we really need is to to go a little
deeper is you know we have like
cereal dieters and the and we know what
to do but we're having difficulty doing
it which means we have to take a
different approach
because because it's if if the diet
worked then we wouldn't have this
epidemic of people struggling with food
with weight with body image all of that
okay so let's pause there one the energy
level is already much better you guys
you guys hear it already see the thing
that makes me crazy and you're already
going the energy is already better than
feeling slim and healthy right right
perfect and this is it's always easier
talking to people than talking to a
camera but this is the skill set to
develop so that's already great next use
you instead of we
okay
not we but you
okay you're talking to the person
and then last is what is the opinion so
you don't need another fad diet what you
need is
what you need to take a different
approach because what is the approach
though what is like what do they need is
to take a deeper dive and look at the
deeper the deeper reasons why you might
be stuck in this self-sabotaging
behavior because once you start to
uncover that it's going to be
so for instance
a lot of people that i work with they
don't feel safe to lose weight so the
best diet in the world is not going to
help them to feel safer in their bodies
like their weight is their shield right
so if if if you take off the weight and
you don't feel safe you feel even more
vulnerable and less safe you put it
right back on again and that's up and
down right so the approach is to inside
out approach to start to look deeper
within and look at some of the core
reasons that you're in this pattern and
it's not because you're bad or you're
not smart enough or you're or you're not
don't have enough willpower it's because
the approach has to be different the
approach that you've been doing
has not been working so the problem is
it's an emotional problem it's an
emotional problem it's a it's actually a
three-fold program a physical emotional
and a spiritual problem i don't
necessarily have to use spiritual but
it's a body mind and spiritual problem
so for instance yesterday i was working
with someone who she's you know she's
i'm coaching her and she's starting to
drop some weight and already she's
snacking every night and we so i didn't
look at so much of like let's get more
disciplined and let's get more strong i
asked her how does it how did it feel
the last time you dropped weight and it
didn't feel safe for her so the
opportunity was to start to explore
those times in her life when she didn't
feel safe to be an attractive woman okay
so this is great so here's what here's
what you do and start to interrupt but
just like to
get it going
you make an individual every video
solves a specific problem you don't need
every video to solve every problem right
so the video doesn't have to talk about
mind bodies every single video talk
about all three things so if you have a
story that you want to share around this
one woman and it's great sharing stories
there this problem is about
feeling safe right
so the video is about feeling safe
that's what this one is okay great so so
the the opening though is you don't need
another fad diet to get on and get off
and then feel like a loser again that it
didn't work
right
the reason why you haven't lost weight
is because you don't feel safe to do so
i love it and i'm going to show you a
technique in this video
of how to release that
perfect like that's the first and i'm
using my words and hopefully it's you
know close enough to what you're doing
um
but that's the opening of the video
with that with your energy level just
like you came on and said the thing that
drives me nuts like that kind of energy
level like this matters right this
really really really matters
uh and so
this video then becomes about feeling
safe and then you share your story about
this person that you've helped
and how she didn't feel safe and she was
snacking and she's not snacking because
she's a bad person and she's not
stacking because
xyz reasons she's snacking because she
doesn't feel safe and here's how you get
out of it
and then whatever your solution is you
you're step one step two step three
right right yeah
tapping there tapping to sort of
uncover the
yeah the solution it's your solution
it's great it's not it's but it's not
the lead and and you you need to be
specific around
something that gets you all riled up and
excited
okay and don't try to cover everything
in one video because you're going to
make another video so don't
maybe this video has nothing to do with
spirituality or
the other pillars that you cover this is
just about feeling safe
okay and then you're making another
video next week so you have another
story to share and talk about um i would
i would love to see you be able to go
more than one a week only for the reason
well two reasons one youtube really
favors and any platform will favor more
content
and two it's just it's really hard to
get good at something if you're only
doing it once a week okay anything
so i think two a week is good to start
or
i mean whatever you can do okay if
you're not consistent at all one a week
if you're at one a week three times a
week if you're out three times a week
daily
[Laughter]
and and the better that you
the more you do it the faster it look
it'll come and the better you'll get
just like any other
skill that you pick up and learn
okay great
welcome everybody uh live see some
familiar faces so what was the topic
today writing emails that get attention
ooh
i think the most important part of the
email sequence is your story
you know i think when you think about
how does somebody join your email list
they they heard about you somewhere they
saw your youtube video they they got
your lead magnet if you think about how
do people find my how do people get on
my email list well they're coming from a
youtube video and i give them some bonus
right um
our campaign right now is we create pdf
summaries for every video and then if
you want the summary
all of them give us your email and we'll
send you the link to the summaries and
then we keep updating that summary page
so they're coming from youtube summary
worksheet for every video great get the
email um
on clubhouse
it's if people want the recording of the
video of the of the soundtrack so
there's a audio stream playing
if people want the recording of it dm me
on clubhouse on instagram the word
clubhouse and we'll send you the link to
the recording
um so you know all these things can lead
to funneling into your email address but
when people
find you and they get on your email list
they don't really know much about you
they're not your hardcore fans
right they're just diving into your
world for the first time and so more
important than
the headline and like getting emails
like grab attention like the best ones
are building a relationship with the
audience so one of the things that i had
to do
was
really dive into letting people know
more about my journey so
if you just get on my email list now
uh that that we're going to give you
whatever we promise you're going to get
your bonus your download whatever we
said we're going to give you but after
that this is going to be a man behind
the channel
emails which is who who's evan
carmichael who's making who's making
this content why do i do what i do and
it's basically just sharing a lot of
what's on my website already the
homepage sharing the story and i made a
video version of it
and and sharing that with people so that
they get to know me a little bit more
because if you want to
write emails that get attention to the
question from jessica
more important than just a headline is
thinking about i'm opening up like i'm
going to open up every email that i get
from zane
because i know zayn because i love zan
zane's like doing prayer hands he's like
yes i made it
i made it you've officially made it
saying you know i'm opening up every
email from zan because
because i love zan
you know and listen
zan and i haven't even met in person
you know we've met we've met on zoom
um
so because i love zen i'm open up and
that's that's what you want to create
the relationship with
with people who are on your list
that it's not just about tricking them
with the right headline but that they
want to open up every email because they
love you so how they're going to love
you well you have to build a
relationship with them well how do you
do that
you're not going to be talking to them
individually to introduce yourself so
it's through the stories that you're
sharing a lot of people see
my
my content my emails my videos and say i
feel like i know you and they start
saying hey how's nina and how are the
dogs and how was your trip last week to
like do i know you
it's a little scary at the beginning
when people kind of knew a lot about my
life now now you just kind of get used
to it but but that means you're doing
something well that people feel like
they know you even though you have no
idea who they are
and so
i think that's the most important
strategy and maybe the the curveball the
unexpected one because what you put in
your subject line matters and you can
study different copywriting techniques
and you can look at save all the emails
that you opened from other people
from from people that you signed up to
look at the emails that you open and
what headlines were they so that it you
know you have your swipe file your
marketing swipe file that you can model
um and those are all great tactics you
can use but i think on top of all of
that the more important thing is
learning to build a relationship with
the people on your list so they feel
like they know you
uh even if you have no idea who they are
so that's my uh that's my hot take
that's what i got
uh let's turn it over to you guys if you
got questions how can i help whatever's
on your mind business life book related
even non-book related if i can if i can
be a resource it's a pretty intimate fun
group so you just unmic
and uh let me know what you got who
wants to go first i just recently hired
my first full-time employee i'm curious
thank you
look at that exciting dude it's a very
exciting moment and i it was last week
when when you started and i'm very
excited and
i'm curious if you have any input any
any wisdom to share with how the uh
mentorship coaching guidance
um uh
how that looks with your team is it a
weekly
event uh that you check or is it
one-on-one with your team members i'm
curious uh if you have any insights on
that yeah so
it's a little different now that we've
got 37 people on the team versus one
and um that's honestly one of my biggest
uh
not regrets but like it gets me sad that
i don't know everybody on my team as
well as i used to when i had
one per like one person oh my gosh it's
great it's just one person it's so
fantastic or five people that like at
some point you it just isn't as
you don't have as many hours in the day
to do it um
what i would do is first off if you just
hired him the training becomes really
important the training and the
onboarding the care and the and the
kindness and expect him to make mistakes
and and be there a lot of times when we
first hire somebody he's like oh yes
great
they're just going to do all this stuff
for me and then
and then you guys oh my god why are they
taking up social my time like you you it
takes more time to do the thing at the
beginning because you have to train them
how to do the thing and they're slower
at it than you do so it's just
expecting that expecting mistakes what's
more important is the is the effort
there is the willingness to learn there
and then ultimately are they coming up
with new ideas that you hadn't thought
of
if you're just hiring someone to do
tasks versus projects right like a task
is i will tell you what to do you go do
it versus a project where you say hey
this is our goal
here's what we've done so far but i'm
empowering you to come up with other
things that might work
right so if you're going to give
somebody what is what's this person
doing for you
project management operations operations
manager
okay so you know we could say hey this
is how i've done my operation so far
but
i i i want to empower you to come with
ideas yourself like don't just take what
i do as
the rule of law and the only way to do
it
come up with ideas for how it can be
better as well
um
so then they then they're more invested
they have more fun doing it and it also
frees up more of your time to
to go off and do the things that you
want to go off and build
so the beginning lots of training
training training training open door
policy
expect mistakes expect to drop some
balls
you know expect to have more time
invested to make that happen
afterwards i would have two different
kinds of meetings
i think a weekly if you have one person
a weekly call
i'm assuming they're not with you like
they're not in the same
yeah correct he's in the philippines and
i'm doing daily daily calls with them
right now which will probably taper uh
yeah i'm so on the same wavelength as
you training training training yeah yeah
perfect so a weekly call
to
just
be operations focused
of of tasks like hey here's what has to
get to how how are we on here how are we
on here what are they responsible for
um and just
connecting but on the work
and then on a second call which doesn't
have to be once a week even once a month
is probably fine
to
to go over life
you know because i think your goal at
least my goal with people is i want them
to be better humans
because of
being in my company
and so
whether you love you know there's some
people who give
bill to serve to everybody on their team
and then okay what's your what's your
who
because if you know that they're who is
respect
you know how to talk to them
what they value more than if it was
something else right if they're who was
family you know you know what's
important to them and so
more life like what does this person
want out of life
and how can you
help them
and also just a bigger picture of every
time i'm doing one of these calls with
someone on my team i'm always asking
what do you love about the work that
you're doing right now what do you not
like about the work that you're doing
right now
and how many hours do you want to be
working
so that gives a good indicator of where
they you know what new ideas they could
grow into
if they don't like it it doesn't mean
that they have to stop doing it but i'm
looking i'm looking for ways to automate
it or reduce i don't want
a bunch of frustrated people on the team
and then how many hours will shift like
sometimes
um
if he's starting off if he's full-time
so let's say he's doing 40 hours a week
maybe he wants to go to 50 or 60 or
maybe
life is getting in the way and he needs
to take care of his mom and he wants to
go down to 30. like you you don't know
and a lot of times people are too afraid
to ask
for a change
um and so that's where hey if you're
saying how many hours how many hours do
you want to be working i'm okay with
anything it doesn't mean we can change
it right now
but if you're at 40 and you want to be
at 60
let me think of some ideas over the next
couple months to try to get you there
that's your goal
um
i'm always behind the scenes looking for
ways to
to um
leverage their skills
and their background and their interest
so like what did he do before coming to
you what did he love about that job what
did he hate about that job is he an
analytical person that can give more
like ops it sounds i mean hopefully if
he's in charge of ops he's attention to
detail analytical um
so
the job that you hire for
is a good starting point but as you
build and grow a company
it needs to be somebody who can take on
a whole bunch of different things
right because you're going to be in a
different spot in a year in two years
and you want people to be able to build
and grow you know within you
so
right now there's some people i meet
weekly some people i meet monthly some
people meet quarterly
and it's a stretch you know to meet
everybody 37 people on the team
um
having a different spot though for the
operation stuff like did you do this did
you do that did you do this where are we
at right that should be a weekly call
but having it in a different spot
compared to even like switch up your
switch up where you are or switch up the
day so my personal development ones or
just getting to know people better
is on a sunday
and it's sunday morning coffee it's a
dif i'm wearing a different vibe i'm not
in like a go go go rush okay i gotta get
to the next thing um zen and i did one
not too long ago
um
and i grabbed my coffee and it was you
know seven in the morning or something
for him uh and and was like hey what
what's up what you know what he it was a
little different because it was more
like helping zan with his business and
what he was doing
um
but typically is trying to find
just ways that you can help them be a
resource for them but having it on a
different day
or even if you're gonna have it in a
different location like if you're
sitting on the couch
like you are now versus sitting being at
your desk or your office or whatever
it's a different vibe it's a more
relaxed
tone um and we'll often tell them hey
it's coffee with evan and if it's
somebody in the philippines they have a
decaf tea or something
and you know like little cheers and
it's like we're having a
coffee meeting
um but trying to combine them i found
didn't work because when you're in
operations mode
you're just kind of
trying to get to the next thing and also
when i when i put it on a on a weekday i
would just rush it
to get to the next
um like okay i know i only have half an
hour here so we got to make this time
count how can i help benji what do you
got
which isn't really conducive to having a
maybe life-changing conversation um
yeah so
i think i think you're doing it and then
then you're just looking at how do i how
do i help this person grow and it may be
on you to push
people into things that they may not see
because they may not see what
you see in them
and that becomes your job to help them
see like maybe that maybe the person you
bring on is really analytical ops focus
but they have a creative streak for some
reason you know like they're on their on
their instagram they're posting their
drawings or something and maybe you give
them thumbnail design as an experiment
you know like you just
you vibe with them when you see what
they might might fit into
sandra says philippines is a coffee
country yeah the problem is it's 10 a.m
for me which is then 10 or 11 p.m
depending on on the time the eastern the
uh what is the daylight savings time so
um yeah if you can drink coffee at 11
p.m that's pretty cool but i know i
would be up all night
let me add this also why evan is still
here and
on the other end
i'm speaking for myself they would
appreciate it they value it so much you
know i get to talk to evan on a sunday
early in the morning like you love it
even though it's early but you love it
so on your end they're gonna really
value it and like they're gonna be
excited because they get to talk to you
on a
on like on a sunday on a relaxed day
like evan was saying
yeah unfortunately it's actually not
that hard to stand out as a as a
boss most bosses suck like most and i
don't even think i was in boss but but
most most employers suck
you know especially if you're hiring are
you hiring through upwork or what
services you use
i
funny enough i had i
know we're out of time i had a post on
upwork but i posted across all my social
media platforms and then a friend of
mine saw my facebook post and said
andrew i got the perfect guy you got to
meet him if you don't hire him i will
and my friend
couldn't have been more right i got on
uh an interview without within the last
at the end of the hour i said you're
you're my guy you're my guy and it's it
was it's quite a
a transformation to shift from a
non-employer to an employer and i'm
still adjusting to that mindset it's a
new way of looking at myself but
very very very excited with the future
what the future holds now even just
asking like
how are you doing
yeah every now and then
[Laughter]
yes
i on on monday uh i took my i was on my
walk in the morning and i just i sent
them a video message
to each person on my team
i sent one to zen too
um
and there was nothing it's like hey zan
i'm on my walk
happy monday i was thinking about you
today um
just thank you for being
in our community built to serve coach
appreciate you so much and i hope you
have a great start to your week since
like
terrible lighting i don't know i'm just
walking it's cold i'm just walking press
record and i did that for everybody in
the team like a a 15 second video it's
not a it's not an essay or giant thought
leadership thing just a quick but
everybody
loves it
you know so just
the standards are so low for being a
good employer that it's it's not that
hard to stand out just by like being a
good person and caring about somebody
and asking how they're doing but i think
that even that is even though that's a
crazy high standard for most people that
that's still nothing compared to which
it could do
um
and so yeah i think at a minimum just
figuring out once a month to get
together to talk not talk about business
but their role and where they could go
and it'll be it's fulfilling for you too
to feel like you're helping somebody
believe more themselves and create more
of themselves and where they're at right
now so
that was powerful thank you so much evan
i really appreciate that i think next
year like in 2022 evan's gonna call
everybody and have the oprah effect you
get a car you get a car you get a car
zane needs a new car is that what's
happening today no no
uh anyway cool and super happy for you
man congrats i think you'll be a great
just knowing you i think you'll be an
awesome leader um
and that person is lucky to have you you
know as a as a as a boss i guess um
and keep us posted come on back and let
us know
struggles challenges wins
um
but i'm out of time thank you guys for
the love and we'll see you very soon
thank you evan
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love